[Music]
uh you're not even gonna believe that
this one's news and i was so upset but
uh it is perfect for us
a man
says he is laughed at and hung up on
after complaining to his local uk
chinese restaurant that he found a
chicken foot in his takeaway yeah you
got a bonus you got a [ __ ] bonus
there that's so funny why is he mad
because he's not used to eating chicken
feet he's like why is there a chicken
feet in my chicken why do you call it
takeaway
the man said he was left feeling
physically sick
that he has been put off of chicken
altogether
oh you don't like chicken anymore go
[ __ ] yourself dude
be a man bro the equivalent of getting a
curly fry in the mcdonald's i know right
just being this guy's being like oh why
is it curly
that should be straight
yeah this reminds me of this one time
where i saw an article where it was like
they were
mad that they didn't cook the meat from
the
place yeah because it's god yeah it says
rare beef that's so stupid it's meant to
be like that because you [ __ ] throw
it in afterwards hey dude just throw the
microwave stop being a [ __ ] that's like
like on any korean bbq you dig in the
yelp enough you'll see someone that said
they expected us to cook it ourselves
yeah for real
and the entitlement i think that's the
funny thing is they think they know what
it's supposed to be like yeah yeah
that's so [ __ ] hilarious this guy
sucks yeah the customer who wished to
remain anonymous contacted take away to
complain about the crispy foot but said
that it looked good yeah but he said
they brushed them off and hung up the
phone
they're like get the [ __ ] out yeah that
shit's not illegal you got a crackerjack
prize man it's good good right fried
food
it's a fried gang sign of some sort yeah
just throw it away you don't like it
throw it away
no but he's put off by the foot
the chicken that he ate even cut off the
nails for him
that's service service yeah so he goes
he said
this is what he said he goes i honestly
didn't even process it at first
i pulled out the first piece of chicken
took a bite
following this i looked into the meal
and noticed the oddly shaped piece which
made me put out what i had in my mouth
in disbelief yeah it stopped tasting
like chicken apparently once you saw it
where it came from
i just love reading this from our side
of the culture that's [ __ ] funny dude
these savages i can't
believe as anyone would imagine seeing
what i was holding on my hand really put
me off the rest of my mail
tough [ __ ] how did this become news did
he send this to the newspaper like hey
you guys got to hear about my story you
got to i got to speak my truth
can you believe they try to poison me
it's like what does he think like all of
a sudden the drumstick is fine but the
other attachment to it is like [ __ ]
deadly yeah he has so much to say he and
then he goes i literally had to google
chicken body parts to make sure i wasn't
telling myself it was what it wasn't
what he went that far so drew sojourn i
knew i couldn't continue eating the meal
i physically felt sick after around 15
minutes of getting my head around what i
had actually been served i called the
takeaway back and explained to them what
had happened this is my favorite part
after trying to explain to them what
they had served me they just went silent
laughed and then seconds later the line
went dead good you're responsible you're
probably talking [ __ ]
okay because in their minds they're like
bro you just got free peace
you just got another free people oh it's
more money yeah we didn't charge you
enough that's a completely separate dish
than what you ordered a polar opposite
experience right that guy sucks dude i
remember um you know uh uh the siwat the
bone
the meat thing where you get like um
when you make a bone broth i don't even
know if i'm pronouncing it right this is
that really laughing but then they have
like the pork and the beef bones stuck
and you could just get that right so our
buddy would get that and
um i didn't know you were supposed to
eat the merrell part yeah so that's the
best part right so i would just eat
around it and i'm like oh these meats
are soaked into the soup that's so good
and i remember we're like last time they
came was just bones and i'm like yo bro
it's only bones what about the meat on
the ends and stuff and he's like no no
no the good part's in the mirror and i'm
like my friend didn't even explain that
last time and i tried and i was like yo
this is so good but i did i did the kind
of stupid part where i'm like man you
gave us nothing but bones we want the
ones with the meat on it yeah
and then you learned yeah yeah you
learned i didn't [ __ ] throw a fit
like did you go right to the newspaper
and say i mean this guy will never eat
chicken again because of this good he
doesn't deserve it
he doesn't deserve it what is he doing
at a chinese restaurant anyway that's
what i'm saying what do you i wonder
what is like the rest fried chicken i
know
man okay what's one thing you guys
wouldn't eat dog wouldn't eat yeah
something that might be like
i like something that might be like
dangerous to me like fugu i'm like kind
of like on the fence what's that is that
that puffer fish yeah because that's
like kind of depending on like who
prepares it like you might nice roll of
sushi yes yeah but it sounds like oh but
you like crap so is it delicious to the
point where people say it's worth the
risk i think it's something different
they're going for that mouth feel
because it numbs your mouth out and
stuff so it's like kind of a novelty but
if they'd [ __ ] it up then you could die
and people do die every year because you
have to write a you have to go
yeah there's some people that die yeah
because it's only some so oh damn yeah
do you have to do a waiver yeah yeah and
it's a little bit of poison as well
someone unqualified preparing it it's
like they usually [ __ ] up because you
have to be licensed to prepare it so if
you prepare it and you accidentally like
hit the wrong sack there then it
releases more poison into the meat and
then if it's above a certain dose
because you want a little bit of the
poison to like numb your mouth out but
too much and then you die oh wow now i'm
good i'm good on that so [ __ ] like that
is like stuff uh maybe i don't need it
you know fugu roulette anyone oh my god
i feel like if bart ate that and he got
a little poison he gets stronger
you get like his ass is fatter yeah yeah
yeah it all goes his ass becomes the
pufferfish
this guy dude that's what will happen i
don't eat that stuff that's scary dude
i'll eat mostly anything else at least
try it once yeah i'll try i'll try most
things what's the craziest thing you
have tried already thus far
it's the craziest thing that i've tried
crocodile kangaroo uh i actually
wouldn't mind any of those nah that's
cool maybe like like frogs kind of make
me feel sometimes
good though it's good but it but it
[ __ ] with me that's like it's a frog
the thought of it that's what [ __ ] up
but it's good though it's good no it's
delicious yeah have you eaten just about
everything that like like most exotic
foods yeah pretty much i when i went to
dubai i wanted to try camel meat how's
that oh
i said i wanted to try i didn't get to
have you tried bear
no i haven't is it hard to come by come
with me like is it just like you gotta
do special
no it's not but like we just didn't have
a chance to what is the craziest street
food thing you've eaten horse meat just
like
what'd you think of it
no like
literally
no i went to vietnam and my auntie's
neighbor literally was like
making horse like she killed a horse and
she was
she was cooking it on the side of her
house in like big pots and she was
delivering it to her neighbors oh how
she made like stewing it or it was a
stew and then someone was grilled and it
was probably one of the tastiest oh [ __ ]
and the most fragrant meat that i've
ever had what did you prefer the braised
i had the horse the grilled i had horse
in japan
um
because like when you go in there like
it was like a like a japanese barbecue
place
and then instead of like places where
you see like a lot of cows and pictures
of cows you just see horses everywhere
and they're like oh it's interesting oh
you didn't know you were in a horse
restaurant we didn't know until we were
like we're so hungry and then we're just
like
uh we'll [ __ ] we'll just stay here and
then we started asking and oh yeah we
could serve horse here and it was really
good it was like juicy yeah it was like
for like a lean meat it's like the
juiciest meat i've ever had it's a
comfortable sweet a little bit too very
fragrant like it smells really good did
you go
[Music]
or did it [ __ ] you up to like now where
you see horses like because you know you
see horses like i like to write that now
you're like i'd like to eat that
i don't have that connection
i can't even look at cows that way still
even though oh no i look at cows like
that i'm just like oh you don't go
cheese
[Laughter]
that's the crazy thing about you you
never had anything that great i don't
think i've ever i feel like i mean
everything that i've had is like i feel
like it's pretty tame by most like asian
standards like pig's blood and stuff
like that
it's like we were just eating that
i don't know if i could say this i might
get cancelled for this but when i was
younger living in vietnam i my my dad
sent me dogs oh
i mean
you you didn't go and buy it at the
wuhan
ruling what was the woodland dog
festival yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah the woolen woolen dog festival
the eulogy yeah yeah yeah was it good
that's just crazy
so like my dad ate dog all the time back
in china yeah was it good do you
remember i i don't remember it but i do
remember like um our dogs like that at
the house would get stolen all the time
oh man so that actually just happened
more food for food yeah cause my dad
told me he's like honestly dog is like
the best meat ever wow that's what they
tell me yeah and then like when we had a
german shepherd oh my dad loved him like
crazy but like one of the things he
would do is [ __ ] around with him it's
like he likes to put him on his side and
he'd go you see this neck part it's the
most delicious
you see this part it goes and he always
looks at him he always and my dog love
my dad so much he would like to grab him
he goes you don't [ __ ] listen to eat
your ass i feel like you're gonna eat me
right now
but then he ended up like cooking food
for him remember you'd have like a big
thing you ended up cooking him
no like my dad cooked for the dollar you
love the dog so much it's just like a
different connection yeah like you love
the dog as like a family member but he
has no problem eating dogs it's like
having a pig as a pet yeah yeah there's
also such a big difference between
eating something here in la that was
like weird versus you're just in china
and everybody's [ __ ] eating it yeah
like if when the dude hands you you want
something he pass you the phone it's all
turtles
on the phone like you're getting a
[ __ ]
like what do you got like uber eats or
something and it's all turtles yeah
that's what they would do they'd be like
we were working out there they'd be like
you guys want anything so you think oh
you just like [ __ ] you can pick
anything but literally i kept scrolling
it was just turtles like different kinds
yeah you got tortoise ready or slider
and you're just like i don't i don't
want a reptile like that might make me
throw up dude i had like the turtle
blood soup oh my god is it good it's
like the raw turtle blood with like
peanuts and [ __ ] whoa
was it good no
not a fan though not a fan what's the
thing that you thought you were gonna
dislike a lot but loved a lot oh that's
a good question like you went into it
being like i'm gonna hate this and
you're like yeah that's great
or vice versa what do you go into a lot
of people react to balot that way mm-hmm
yo you're not eating it
ain't nothing to you yeah you like that
with durian but luke's pretty good like
people are like oh i don't know if i can
eat you're gonna hate it and then you
loved it yeah i served durian at my
first pop-up oh you did in west
hollywood it was like people actually
loved it like there were a couple how'd
you serve it um on an it was a ice cream
during the night oh that's a good one
that's a good way to eat it yeah yeah
yeah i i was like shocked when i saw
balut and i was like dude this is
[ __ ] crazy but when you eat it you're
like it's something so familiar yeah
yeah have you had the vietnamese like
style of eating it what's the difference
between filipino vietnamese stuff oh i
think it's like just the different
sauces on the side like vietnamese we
eat it with like salt pepper lime and a
vietnamese coriander oh no i just had it
with salt yeah because we did it here
for challenge is the vietnamese one
typically dog chicken or quail or is it
like a specific
foul it's duck it's always done right
yeah because the pig is my favorite it's
a big old egg yeah
i remember eating stir-fried uh stingray
in malaysia whoa that was pretty that
sounds exotic man oh yeah we are some
interesting things out there like snails
and whatever but it's like what part of
the stinger are you really eating like
the little flappy part a little some
some parts would be tough some parts
would be kind of
tough it is it is
you don't want some stingray face
the way it sounds and they always look
like they're smiling and [ __ ] i know
they're so cute apparently they're
gasping for air
when they're doing that like when you
like pull them out of the water they're
like oh they're making that face they're
like
i've died
and we're like
just ruined stingray for me before i got
the chance yeah
do